كان عام 2022 هو العام الذي كان فيه العالم جاهزًا
لتذاكر الإقلاع
المحجوزة في أكياس معبأة وكان
المسافرون المرهقون متحمسون للوصول إلى
السماء ، فالطلب المكبوت كبير الذي
ننتظره ومستعدون للسفر في العام الماضي
مشهدًا بعد مشهد يذكرنا
بمسرحيات الطيران  دور فريد في جمع
الناس معًا في أستراليا ،
دموع الفرح حيث احتضنت العائلات هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين لم يروا عائلاتهم
منذ عامين تقريبًا أحفاد لم يروا أبدًا
أقاربهم المرضى الذين كانوا
ذاهبين لزيارة
الاحتفالات في الولايات المتحدة كزوار من
أوروبا كانوا  تم السماح بالدخول والترحيب
بالعودة بأناقة ، كانت الضجة على متن الطائرة
رائعة وقصص الأشخاص الذين تم لم شملهم
ولكن الأحباء الذين لم يروهم منذ
أكثر من 600 يوم مؤثر للغاية ، وكان هناك
وعد بإعادة ظهور رحلات العمل
وليس هناك بديل شخصي
لقد اعتدنا جميعًا على التفاعل مع
مؤتمرات الفيديو ، لكننا جميعًا
تعلمنا حدود مؤتمرات الفيديو ،
فأنا متفائل تمامًا الآن حيث
يأتي سفر الشركات  مرة أخرى في الوقت المناسب
، لم يكن العام خاليًا من المشاكل ، ولا
يزال الكثيرون يتسمون بنقص العمالة المتنوع من
omicron واستمرار عمليات
الإغلاق في الصين طالما
أن صناعة الطيران في الصين لا تعمل بكامل طاقتها ،
فلا يمكن قول هذه الصناعة على مستوى العالم على
الإطلاق  لكي تتعافى تمامًا
بعد أن كانت حيوية للغاية خلال عام 2020 ،
استمرت الشحنات في لعب دور صناعي مهم في
مساعدة البلدان على إعادة الانفتاح والمساعدة في
إعادة بناء الاقتصادات ،
فنحن نحمل الأدوية ، ونحمل قطع الغيار التي
نحملها ، ونحمل الماشية ، ونحمل
المواد الغذائية
كل ما في ذهنك ونحمله
و  هناك الكثير ليأتي مع
بعض البلدان الأكثر صرامة التي من المقرر
إعادة فتحها وبعض الوجهات المفضلة في العالم التي
تنتظر الزوار تتمتع
خطوط الطيران اليوم بموقع أفضل
من أي وقت مضى
لتوفير اتصال لمساعدة
العالم على النمو